[MUSIC]
I want you to take a moment and picture
the place where you feel most alive.
The place where you feel energized,
happiest, maybe in the zone.
Take a moment to look
around your happy place.
And notice what you see,
what you smell, what you hear.
For me, my happy place is a grassy field
in New Hampshire, riding my horse Brutus.
The sun is warm and the air is fresh,
and I take a deep breath and
feel alert and energized.
But also relaxed.
I've asked a lot of people
about their own happy places.
And what I found is that people
prefer all sorts of different places.
Some like it loud, others like it quiet.
Some prefer to be inside, while others
love to be surrounded by nature.
But what I have found, is that no
one's happy place looks like this,
the traditional office.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Today, I want to share with you how
we can build happier, healthier,
more productive spaces for people.
It's a concept that I've described to
many of you as wellness real estate.
The truth is we spend
a lot of our time indoors.
In fact, as Americans,
we spend over 90% of our lives inside.
That means that the built environment
can have a drastic impact on
our health and well-being.
As future business leaders, I want to
provide you with the information and
tools you need to build
better organizations.
By understanding what healthier
spaces look and feel like.
In an increasingly competitive market
there's never been a better time
to understand what truly impacts
health and productivity.
For the last five years,
I've been working at companies that
aim to make buildings healthier.
The opportunity for impact is massive,
as health is the fastest growing and
arguably most important market.
And real estate is the world's
largest asset class.
Most recently, I've been working
with the Well Building Standard,
which is a building certification program
that aims to make buildings healthier.
Through design, operations,
and also policies.
Today I want to share with you my favorite
Well concepts, where I see the greatest
opportunity for impact, air and light.
Let's start with air.
When you think about poor air quality,
you probably imagine
people wearing face masks.
Walking around in smoggy environments
typically in developing cities.
Or if you were in California last year
during the fires, you may picture yourself
walking outside and feeling the soot
in the air hit your nose and eyes.
But even if there isn't smog,
and even if there aren't fires,
outdoor air quality can be fairly poor.
And what's concerning is that
indoor air can actually be 2 to 5
times more contaminated than outdoor air.
And what's concerning about
indoor air is that many of
the contaminants we find
inside are actually invisible.
In 2014 Harvard did a study that
brought this idea of healthy indoor
air quality and work together.
They did this by studying common office
workers doing common office tasks.
And looked at how they were responding
in terms of crisis response and
decision making.
They showed that by increasing
the amount of fresh air in a space and
decreasing the amount of
contaminants in that space.
They could improve
outcomes by nearly 300%.
How did they do this?
They started by replacing furniture,
office supplies, and cleaning products,
with equivalent products that didn't off
get as many contaminants into the indoor
environment.
They also thought about how much
fresh air was coming through a space.
I'm sure we can all picture ourselves
sitting in a stuffy conference room
feeling sleepier and sleepier.
Or how many of you can picture
yourself in an airplane,
waiting to take off, feeling sleepier and
even a little bit dizzy?
Both of these responses are a result
of too many people in a small space,
breathing out carbon dioxide
without enough fresh oxygen
coming through that space.
Luckily, there's an easy solution for
this, called demand
controlled ventilation.
With demand control
ventilation sensor sits
in a potentially densely occupied room.
And as more people come
into that space and
breathe out carbon dioxide,
the building's mechanical system
automatically pushes more
fresh air into that space.
Now that we're all air experts,
let's talk a little bit about light.
With a show of hands, how many of
you use night shift on your iPhone?.
And for those of you with your hands up,
keep them up there.
How many of you know why you use
night shift on your iPhone?.
All right, about half the room is
an expert already in this space, perfect.
For those of you with your hands up,
you know that our eyes are for
more than just seeing.
Our eyes, or more specifically,
our optic nerves are responsible for
perceiving the amount and color
temperature of light in any given space.
Let's take a step back in time
to think about why this is,
back to a time before electricity when we
relied on the sun for most of our light.
In the morning as the sun rose,
we saw bright white blue tones of light,
telling our bodies to wake up and
be alert.
And in the afternoon and evening as the
sunset, we saw warmer tones of light or
golden tones.
Telling our bodies to relax and
start preparing for sleep.
This 24 hour sleep wake cycle is
known as our circadian rhythm, and
it determines many of
our bodily functions.
So what happens when
we disrupt that cycle?
For example, when we see bright white-blue
iPhone light right before we go to sleep?
Well, we're telling our
bodies to wake up and
be alert,
instead of actually going to sleep.
And we wonder why we have so
many sleep disorders.
And what happens when we sit under
the same office lighting, all day long.
Well, in the US and
in many cities across the world,
typical office lighting is
warm in color temperature.
So it's actually telling us to prepare for
sleep all day long.
Luckily, there are easy solutions for
this as well.
Having access to natural daylight can
keep our circadian rhythms in line.
And even when we don't have
access to natural daylight,
we can think about the design
of our overhead lighting.
Or even add a task light to a workstation
that can give us the right amount and
color temperature of
light throughout the day.
With this new insight, I want to take
you to another one of my happy places.
But first, picture my commute,
a bustling New York City Street,
stepping off of a crowded subway platform.
All of this business disappears as
I step in and out of the elevator,
into Delos Headquarters, my office.
What always hits me first is the quiet.
Thanks to carefully designed acoustical
panels on the ceiling, walls, and floor.
The space is nearly silent.
15 active green walls greet me when I walk
in, not only adding greenery to the space,
but they have special
nodes on their roots.
That are pulling contaminants
out of the indoor air.
My arrival has triggered the lights
to turn on bright white-blue
because it's morning.
But I know that over
the course of the day,
they'll fade to a golden color
temperature, helping me prepare for sleep.
I take a deep breath of fresh air and
I feel alert.
I smell a little bit of nature thanks to
the wooden staircase that connects our
2 floors.
I know the workday must begin,
but it doesn't all seem so bad.
As I grabbed organic
banana from the cafe and
sit down in my ergonomically
adjustable chair.
My mind is clear.
Now you may be thinking that we can't
all work in an office like Delos, but
Delos wasn't just designed with
its own employees in mind.
It was designed as a demonstration space,
to show people what it looks and
feels like, to be in a space that
was designed with people in mind.
And other major players like CBRE and
even Microsoft they
are implementing wellness design.
You may also be thinking that all
of these seems expensive, but
luckily it isn't more expensive.
It's simply smarter design.
And even where there
are small increases in cost
there's a clear return on investment.
The American Society of Interior Designers
did a study of their own employees
after moving to a healthier space.
And found increases in
productivity of up to 16%.
As future business leaders, we have
the power to make our employees healthier.
We can build companies that are not only
more profitable, but also better for
our people.
And while it's the right thing to do,
it can also make us more competitive.
We can benefit from increases
in productivity, and
improved attraction, and retention.
My hope is that someday,
our buildings will actually make us better
than when we walk through hat door.
And maybe someday,
our offices will remind us all a little
more of our own happy place, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]